מודלי תכנות הם מפרטים בסיסיים שמגדירים
איך תוכנה בנויה
ומבוצעת, הם מספקים מסגרת
למפתחים להביע אלגוריתמים
ולארגן קוד, לרוב תוך הסתרה של פרטים ברמה נמוכה
של החומרה הבסיסית או סביבת הריצה
מודלים שונים מתאימים לסוגים שונים של בעיות
וארכיטקטורות חומרה, ומציעים
רמות שונות של הפשטה
ושליטה. בפרק הזה
נסקור מודלי תכנות קוונטיים וקלאסיים
ונראה איך אפשר לשלב ביניהם כדי להריץ אלגוריתמים
בצורה הטובה ביותר
נתחיל עם מודל התכנות
למחשב קוונטי. מודל תכנות בסיסי אחד
שמוכר לכמעט כל מפתחי הקוונטום
הוא ה-circuit הקוונטי. לא ניכנס
לפרטים של circuit קוונטי
כאן כי כבר יש לנו הרבה משאבים מעולים
כולל הרצאה של Joan Waters
רק נציין שה-circuit בנוי מ-
סט של קווים שנקראים wires שמייצגים qubits
וגם gates שמייצגים פעולות על מצבים קוונטיים
וסט של מדידות
מושג תכנות חשוב נוסף
ל-
ה-primitives האלה מייצגים את המשימות הכי נפוצות
שמשתמשים מנסים לבצע עם המחשב הקוונטי
יש שני primitives זמינים כרגע
Sampler ו-Estimator. Sampler נותן לך את היכולת
לדגום מצב שהוכן על ידי circuit קוונטי
ו-Estimator מאפשר לך להעריך את ערך התוחלת של
observable עבור מערכת במצב שה-circuit הקוונטי שלך הכין
המושג האחרון
שנדבר עליו בחלק הזה
הוא transpilation. transpilation
הוא התהליך של כתיבת circuit קלט נתון
כדי להתאים לטופולוגיה של מכשיר קוונטי ספציפי
לצורך ביצוע
על מחשבים קוונטיים עם רעש
בדומה למהדרים קלאסיים,
שגרת ה-transpiler משנה בהדרגה
את המבנה של ה-circuit על ידי הפעלת סט של passes
עכשיו בואו נדבר על מודלי תכנות קלאסיים
יש הרבה מודלי תכנות
למחשבים קלאסיים
אבל בפרק הזה נתמקד בשניים
הכי פופולריים: תכנות מקבילי
ו-task workflow. בשימוש בשני המודלים האלה
בשילוב עם מודלי תכנות קוונטיים
אפשר לבטא כמעט כל workflow היברידי
קוונטי-קלאסי של כל רמת מורכבות
מודל התכנות המקבילי
מחלק תוכנית לתת-בעיות שאפשר להריץ
בו-זמנית. יש שני paradigms עיקריים של תכנות מקבילי:
shared memory parallelism ו-distributed memory parallelism
למטרות שלנו כאן, בואו נתמקד במודל distributed memory
מודל distributed memory
משתמש בתהליכים עצמאיים על cores נפרדים
או nodes שבהם לכל תהליך יש זיכרון משלו
והתקשורת מתרחשת באמצעות message passing. יש
כמה מושגים שכדאי להכיר
הראשון הוא process
שהוא מופע עצמאי של התוכנית
שרץ על core נפרד
וגם rank שהוא מזהה ייחודי של ה-process
ואז יש single program
multiple data - מודל הפשטה
שהוא מודל הפשטה
לחישוב שבו מופע יחיד של התוכנית
מופץ לכמה nodes
אז קוד המקור הוא אותו דבר
אבל הנתונים על ה-nodes האלה שונים
מודל התכנות המקבילי של ביצוע
מתרחש בצורה הבאה
תוכנית יחידה מופצת לכמה nodes
ומפעילה כמה תהליכים מקבילים
זרימת הבקרה של התוכנית נקבעת לפי ה-rank
או המזהה של ה-process
והתקשורת מתרחשת
דרך message passing
מודל תכנות task workflow
מפשט חישוב לגרף או DAG
שבו כל node בגרף הוא משימה מסוימת
או job, והקשתות הן תלויות של נתונים
וסדר. דוגמאות אפשר למצוא בתיעוד שלנו
אחרי הכל, הרצף שתמיד מדברים עליו בקוונטום
computing - mapping, optimisation,
execution ו-post processing
הוא מודל תכנות task workflow
שבו כל המשימות מבוצעות אחת אחרי
השנייה בצינור
אבל עם task workflows
אנחנו לא כבולים לסדר ביצוע סדרתי
ויכולים לבצע משימות במקביל
כל משימה או workflow יכולים להיות עבודה מקבילה שלמה
בפני עצמה, אז אפשר לשלב
ולהתאים את המודלים האלה כדי לתאר אלגוריתמים
של כל רמת מורכבות.
בואו ננסה ליישם כמה מהמושגים שלמדנו
על קוד. קודם ננסה להריץ hello world פשוט
עם paradigm תכנות מקבילי
אנחנו הולכים להשתמש ב-Open MPI
שהוא מימוש של פרוטוקול MPI
שהוא התקן ל-message passing
בתכנות מקבילי
קודם צריך שה-program שלנו יהיה מוכן
כאן אנחנו משתמשים ב-mpi4py
שהוא binding של Python
ל-MPI, וכפי שאפשר לראות, אנחנו משתמשים ב-rank כדי להחליט
את זרימת הבקרה של התוכנית
אז בואו נבדוק את סקריפט ה-submission שלנו.
כפי שאפשר לראות, הולכים להשתמש בשני nodes
משימה אחת לכל node ב-normal partition
ובואו נריץ את ה-program - נחכה רגע
ואז נוכל לבדוק את תוצאות העבודה שלנו
כפי שאפשר לראות, יש לנו את פלטי ה-log של ה-program
כאן השתמשנו בשני nodes ושני תהליכים
שמזוהים לפי rank
כפי שאפשר לראות כאן כפלט
rank אפס ו-rank אחד שמשמשים להחליט
את זרימת הבקרה של ה-program שלנו
כפי שאפשר לראות, ה-process של rank אפס שלח
payload מסוים ל-process של rank אחד
וה-process של rank אחד קיבל
אותו. גם נדבר על task workflows
יש כלים שנקראים
workload management systems. הם מיועדים במיוחד
להרצת workflows מורכבים
אבל כדי לא להעמיס, הולכים להשתמש בתכונת ה-dependency המובנית
ב-Slurm
כדי לבנות את הקבוצות החישוביות האלה
קודם צריך שהמשימות של ה-workflow יהיו מוכנות
זה אותו קוד
היתרון שכל אחת מהמשימות האלה
כ-mapping, optimisation, execution
ו-post processing היא שלב נפרד
הוא שאפשר לציין דרישות משאבים ייחודיות
לכל אחת מהמשימות. לדוגמה, mapping, optimisation
ו-post processing לא צריכים
גישה למשאבי קוונטום
לכן אפשר להריץ אותם על classical partition.
אבל משימת execution תצטרך
משאבי קוונטום, לכן הולכים להריץ אותה על quantum
partition.
עכשיו בואו נשתמש בתכונת dependency כדי לשרשר משימות
ל-workflow.
כפי שאפשר לראות, עדיין מריצים
את פקודת ה-sbatch שלנו עם הדגל parsable
שיחזיר את ה-job ID
ואז אפשר להעביר את ה-job ID הזה
כ-dependency למשימות אחרות
לעבודות. כפי שאפשר לראות, מריצים
עבודות ב-workflow עם ה-dependency
ברגע שה-workflow כולו מסתיים, אפשר לבדוק את התוצאות.
וכפי שאפשר לראות, קיבלנו בחזרה את ערך ה-expectation value שלנו.
וגם אפשר לבדוק את כל
התוצאות מכל אחד מהשלבים.
שנמצאות גם כאן.
וזהו לגבי חלק מודל התכנות
בפרק הבא נדבר על אלגוריתמים מתקדמים
יותר